vom wochenende norbert hofer reiste
entschuldigung herr bitte um verzeihung
also jetzt live nach wen es geht um die
politische zukunft der fpö namentlich
des innenministers vormittag meine sehr
verehrten damen und herren ich bedanke
mich für das sehr große interesse an
unserer gemeinsamen erklärung
zweifellos ist es so dass das video das
vor einigen tagen veröffentlicht worden
ist und die inhalte die dort aufgetaucht
sind unentschuldbar sind unter windows
und hc strache haben aus diesen
vorkommnissen die konsequenzen gezogen
ich selbst werde am freitagmorgen davon
informiert worden dass es hier aufnahmen
gibt die höchst problematisch sind war
für mich doppelt schwierig weil ich an
diesem tag termine in innsbruck geplant
hatte und auch selbst hingeflogen bin
und innsbruck es eine der schwierigsten
flughäfen in österreich und dann im
hinterkopf mit diesem wissen dann diesen
schwierigen flug vorzunehmen aber
doppelt belastet
wir wissen natürlich dass das was dort
gesagt worden ist auch viele menschen
verletzt hat und ich möchte mich auch
dafür entschuldigen und kann
sicherstellen dass das was dort gesagt
worden ist nicht das ist was wir in der
fpö dulden und was wir einfach nur so
zur kenntnis nehmen daher ist es wichtig
das heißt die finanzen der partei durch
einen externen wirtschaftsprüfer einer
prüfung zu unterziehen sind ich hab mir
gestern auch die spenden angesehen die
in der partei in den letzten jahren
eingegangen sind und kann man sagen dass
das allesamt keine große beträge sind es
ist eine liste von wenigen seiten es
sind vor allem kleine beträge
der größte betrag nicht gefunden habe
ist von einer landwirtin
das die vorgeschichte erzählen diese
dame ist vor einiger zeit in finanzielle
not geraten
freiheitliche haben sie vor ort
unterstützt mit kleidung für die kinder
und so weiter und diese dame hat dann
später eine erbschaft gemacht und hat
dann 10.000 euro an die fpö gespendet
das war der größte betrag den ich in
dieser richtige tun habe und ich habe
gesagt ich möchte gerne dass dieser
liste auch ihnen als vierte macht im
staat zurückgestellt wird freilich mit
den namen geschwärzt reger und
kleinspenden dass da in die auslage
stellen aber wir werden diese listen
auch veröffentlichen unabhängig davon
werden die finanzen der partei einer
strengen prüfung unterzogen werden
meine damen und herren ich glaube dass
viele von ihnen mich bereits seit
einigen jahren kennen meine stärken
meine schwächen
ich kann ihnen sagen dass der weg den
ich in der politik gegangen bin ein sehr
vielfältiger wahl hat begonnen
in eisenstadt in einer arbeitsgruppe als
organisationsreferent ich habe für
wirtschaftskammerwahlen auch referent
vorbereiter die lagen damals bei knapp
einem prozent
wir haben es dann geschafft das fast 20
prozent bei dieser kamera
ich war bezirksparteiobmann ich war
landesparteisekretär klubdirektor
pressesprecher in einem regierungsbüro
dann später nationalrat worden dritter
präsident des nationalrates sie
besonders schön dass ich bei der letzten
wahl auch sehr viele stimmen erhalten
habe von den mandataren der anderen
parteien sogar mehr stimmen als die von
mir sehr geschätzten kollegen der
anderen parteien die eine funktion als
präsident des nationalrates eingenommen
es war mir immer wichtig ein gutes
verhältnis zu allen anderen parteien zu
pflegen
das betrifft auch die sp ich habe meiner
verantwortung als bundesminister für
verkehr auch die wesentlichen positionen
in der öbb bei der ffg beim patentamt
nicht durch freiheitliche selbst überall
dort stehen an der spitze nach wie vor
sozialdemokraten auch bei den
sektionschefs im bm fit habe ich
hier keine maßnahmen vorgenommen um hier
persönlichkeiten die hervorragende
arbeit leisten und die hat mir einen
anderen parteien angehören dann nicht in
der funktion zu belassen
auch bei der asfinag weiß so prinzip die
dort eine gute arbeit gemacht hat war in
einem mit einer auseinandersetzung mit
dem anderen vorstand der dann auch gehen
musste und es dann auch für uns dieser
auseinandersetzungen zurück getreten hat
mir dann auch gesagt und auch medien
öffentlich gesagt dass wir ein sehr
gutes arbeitsverhältnis haben auch
genauso bei der ravensburger was ich
schade finde ist weil wir es gerade die
diskussion rund um hans peter
haselsteiner haben sie wissen dass im
rahmen des bundespräsidenten wahlkampfs
ja auch diese aufgabe hatte ich ihnen
mit einem recht passablen wahlergebnis
einem fast unendlichen wahlkampf hans
peter haselsteiner sehr aktiv gegen
milch mobil gemacht hat aber das macht
nichts das ist in einer demokratie so es
wäre mir niemals eingefallen dass sich
nur weil er eine andere politische
meinung vertritt dann gesagt hätte in
meiner funktion sein unternehmen und
dürfen keine aufträge bekommen
es gibt eine ganz exakte auftragsvergabe
bei öbb und asfinag ich habe mich dort
nie eingemischt und ich bin froh dass es
auch dort überprüfen und geben soll sie
werden sehen dass die vorstände der
unternehmen höchst korrekt gehandelt
haben sollte noch einmal an der spitze
der öbb sitzt ein sozialdemokrat der
hervorragende arbeit leistet und der
dafür verantwortlich ist dass ich dieses
unternehmen auch so gut entwickelt hat
dass die öbb ist auch im vergleich zur
deutschen bahn
ein unternehmen das sich wirklich sehen
lassen kann
ich werde meine art politik zu machen
auch in dieser neuen funktion fortsetzen
sie wissen dass ich wann immer es geht
nicht unter der gürtellinie an greif ich
mag so etwas nicht ich versuche
konsequente politik zu machen aber ich
versuche auf meinem weg niemanden zu
verletzen das ist mir persönlich ganz
ganz wichtig denn es gibt auch eine zeit
nach der politik und man muss sich dann
auch in den spiegel schauen können
man muss doch sagen können ich habe
meine aufgabe so gut wie irgendwie
möglich gemacht und habe auf diesen
keine menschen verletzt beleidigt wenn
es mir mal passiert dann entschuldige
ich mich auch dafür ich werde diese art
politik zu machen auch in meiner neuen
funktion weiter ausüben
ich möchte mich sehr herzlich bei meiner
familie bedanken die natürlich sehr
darunter leidet das ist wieder umgeplant
und unverhofft so wie damals im
bundespräsidentenwahlkampf eine aufgabe
auf mich zukommt die sehr sehr viel zeit
und sehr viel auch lebensenergie in
anspruch nimmt ich bedanke mich für das
verständnis dass sich aufgebracht wird
und darf meiner familie versprechen dass
auch eine zeit kommen wird wo ich dann
mehr zeit haben werde wahrscheinlich
dann schafft die enkelkinder aber wobei
solche noch nicht in aussicht sind davon
einen großen kinder schon ein alter
hätten wo das möglich wäre ich freue
mich auf jeden fall sehr darauf kann
leider nur den 17 scheint meiner tochter
ist nicht fertig machen wir sind sehr
viel gefahren
meine frau wird diese aufgabe übernehmen
so arbeitet bmw was mich sehr traurig
macht ist ich hätte sehr gerne noch mein
lieblingsprojekt nämlich die nahverkehrs
milliarde umgesetzt
wir haben in den großen städten in
österreich wie graz innsbruck linz
überall ähnliche probleme wie wir sie
heute auch in wiener leben sehr viel
stau und wir unterstützen derzeit wien
und das ist komplett richtig im rahmen
des u bahn baus aber die anderen städte
bekommen vom bund diese unterstützung
nicht wenn wir die co2 ziele erreichen
wollen dann ist es wichtig dass auch
diese städte unterstützt werden damit
der tägliche stau ein ende hat und der
öffentliche verkehr auch ausgebaut wird
ich hoffe sehr dass jene person und ich
würde es mir wünschen dass eine person
die mir in diesem ministerium nach folgt
vielleicht dieses projekt auch weiter
verfolgt ich habe auch immer mit den
landeshauptleuten aller parteien im
rahmen meiner arbeit im pm fehlt ein
hervorragendes verhältnis gepflegt und
bedanke ich mich auch sehr bei den
landesräten für verkehr und bei den
landeshauptleuten für diese wirklich
gute zusammenarbeit
ich bedanke mich auch bei den
mitarbeitern im bm fit bei den sektion
chefs darüber abteilungsleitern aber bei
jedem mitarbeiter und jeder
mitarbeiterin für die tolle
unterstützung
dem erteilt worden ist und ich bedanke
mich auch das möchte ich unterstreichen
bei allen regierungsmitgliedern ich
glaube dass diese regierung in
österreich sehr beliebt war dass wir in
diesem dieser zeit die wir hatten noch
sehr viel weitergebracht haben was war
unser schwerpunkt das thema soziales
dass auch jene menschen denen es in
österreich nicht so gut geht vom staat
unterstützung erhalten die notwendig ist
gleichzeitig auch ein nulldefizit
sicherzustellen und andererseits bei der
frage der zuwanderung einen weg der
vernunft zu gehen nicht dass man sagt
alle menschen die zu uns kommen werden
negativ oder böser das ist nicht der
fall
viele menschen die nach österreich
gekommen sind leisten unglaubliches für
dieses land und auch dafür ein großes
danke aber es gibt auch menschen die das
etwas anders sehen und die vielleicht
straffällig werden wir unser land nicht
schätzen
und ich finde da muss es erlaubt sein
auch klar zu sagen wer ist in österreich
willkommen wenn möchten wir massiv
unterstützen und wo ist der bereich wo
wir sagen müssen nein das geht nicht
hier müssen wir eine klare grenze im
wahrsten sinne des wortes 10 noch einmal
danke an alle regierungsmitglieder auch
an jene der övp besonders auch an gern
als blume mit dem ich in der
koordinierung sehr sehr eng und sehr gut
zusammengearbeitet habe mir das
unendlich leid dass dieses großartige
projekt so zu ende gehen muss
das ist wirklich sehr schade ich darf
auch versprechen dass es keinen
schmutzkübel wahlkampf gehen weil ich
habe heute pressen der früh gelesen dass
so etwas befürchtet oder vermutet wird
ich stehe dafür nicht zur verfügung wir
werden klar aufzeigen was in unserer
inhalte was wollen wir für österreich
umsetzen meine erfahrung ist auch in den
vielen jahren in denen wir
oppositionspolitik gemacht haben man
kann in beiden bereichen als
regierungspartei aber auch in der
opposition
das politische umfeld in österreich
positiv gestalten eine partei die stark
ist kann auch in der opposition durch
die unterstützung der wählerinnen und
wähler politische sache inhalte umsetzen
alles das hat die vergangenheit bewiesen
und auch gezeigt
meine damen und herren wichtig ist mir
auch dass sie wissen ist dass sich ihre
arbeit sehr schätze sie sind als
medienvertreter ein wichtiger teil des
gleichgewichts in diesem land und ich
glaube so gut kennen sie mich auch ich
habe zu vielen journalistinnen und
journalisten immer ein sehr gutes
respektvolles miteinander gepflegt auch
dann wenn einmal die berichterstattung
auch negativ war und ich möchte jetzt
explizit auch ein medium erwähnen ohne
ist die anderen gering schätzen so
wollen ein medium fürs der fpö wahrlich
nicht nahe steht aber die
journalistische arbeit dieser falter im
zusammenhang mit den ereignissen der
letzten tage geleistet hat war nicht
davon geprägt dass sie unfair gewesen
wäre
auch dafür möchte ich mich bedanken
meine damen und herren das ist der große
unterschied zu den ereignissen nach dem
jahr 2000 damals war die fpö eine
zerstrittene partei gespalten
es gab mittelfeld für alle wissen dass
der große unterschied ist heute dass
diese partei in großer einigkeit in
einen wahlkampf gehen wird und diese
einigkeit dass auch sein
die zeigen wird dass ein sehr sehr gutes
ergebnis auch bei der nationalratswahl
möglich sein wird als
regierungsmitglieder haben wir gesagt
stellen wir unsere ämter zur verfügung
wenn die abberufung unseres
innenministers herbert kickl erfolgt
warum tun wir das herbert kickl hat sich
nichts zu schulden kommen lassen es gibt
keine ermittlungen gegen ihn
die argumentation dass wenn ist nun
ermittlungen gegen die fpö geben sollte
ja ein freiheitlicher innenminister der
generalsekretär war im jahr 2017 hier
nicht verantwortlich sein könnte dies
nicht richtig erstens gibt es keine
ermittlungen
zweitens decken sie anders und die
kaiserstraße auch damals war eine
innenministerin verantwortlich
diese causa auch gut abgearbeitet hat
auch hier war alles in bester ordnung
und ich denke mir dass es möglich
gewesen wäre in diesem team auch weiter
zu arbeiten
es tut mir sehr leid wir hätten wirklich
gerne weitergemacht wir hätten noch sehr
sehr viel vorgehabt positiv es vorgehabt
für dieses land
jetzt werden wir einen wahlkampf machen
einen respektvollen wahlkampf in einem
guten miteinander und ich freue mich
auch darauf meine damen und
medienvertreter ich habe ihnen dezember
des jahres 20 17
das amt des innenministers dieser
republik übernommen zwei ganz zentrale
wahlversprechen umzusetzen
das eine ist die sicherheit der
österreichischen bevölkerung zu erhöhen
das vor allem dadurch dass die exekutive
mehr personal zur verfügung gestellt
bekommt dass es eine bessere ausrüstung
gibt dass es eine intakte infrastruktur
gibt aber das ist nur eine komponente
vor allem auch dadurch dass der polizei
in ihrer schwierigen arbeit der rücken
gestärkt wird und ihren der
öffentlichkeit die entsprechende
anerkennung und wertschätzung zum
ausdruck gebracht wird
das zweite ziel ordnung zu machen im
asyl- und im zuwanderungs bereich wo
jahrelang unter rot schwarzer
verantwortung unhaltbare zustände
herbeigeführt worden sind die den
sozialen frieden
die die innere stabilität und die auch
die sicherheit der bevölkerung gefährden
können
vor allem aber für die zukunft unserer
kommenden generationen gefährden
seit dem ersten tag in meinem amt sind
meine mitarbeiter und ich diversesten
angriffen diffamierungen und
unterstellungen ausgesetzt gewesen
ihre urheber und betreiber sind zumeist
jene die für sich immer in anspruch
nehmen andersdenkende zu respektieren
toleranz und pluralität zu leben und
demokratie und rechtsstaatlichkeit hoch
halten zu wollen
in ihrem handeln beweisen sie dann aber
das gegenteil
diese kräfte haben den freiheitlichen
wahlerfolg und die erfolgreichen
regierungsverhandlungen der fpö nie
verwunden
in ihrem weltbild darf ein
freiheitlicher kein regierungsmitglied
sein und der darf schon gar nicht
innenminister der republik werden die
angriffe meine sehr geehrten damen und
herren waren vielfältig und adeligen
mitarbeitern ist aufgrund ihrer
heimatverbundenheit vorgeworfen zu
vorgeworfen worden rechtsextreme zu sein
die rechtsstaatlich korrekte
vorgangsweise im zuge von ermittlungen
der zuständigen wirtschafts und
korruptionsstaatsanwaltschaft im falle
des bvd ist in der öffentlichen
darstellung zu einer erstürmung einem
datenraum oder gar einen putsch unter
meinem kommando und meiner federführung
verdreht worden
gegen mich und meine mitarbeiter wurde
in vielzahl wurden vielzahl anzeigen mit
völlig haltlosen vorwürfen eingebracht
unter immer neuen und unhaltbaren
vorwänden sind reihenweise
misstrauensanträge gestellt worden
und immer wieder wurden diese
unsachlichen ab auch für das ausland
gespielt oder über das ausland
entsprechend verstärkt trotz dieser
begleitumstände meine sehr geehrten
damen und herren ist es uns sehr sehr
gut gelungen in österreich und auch auf
europäischer ebene unsere
wahlversprechen schritt für schritt
umzusetzen dass wir heute zum beispiel
in österreich und auf ebene der
europäischen union nicht mehr von einer
zwangs verteilung von flüchtlingen quer
über den kontinent gegen den willen der
bevölkerung
reden sondern über wirksame kontrollen
an den eu außengrenzen über konsequente
abschiebungen und über ein ende eines
falschen anreiz systems für
wirtschaftsflüchtlinge aus aller welt
das verdankt sich unserer freiheitlichen
arbeit in dieser bundesregierung die
zusammenarbeit mit bundeskanzler kurz
und seinem team war dabei lange eine auf
augenhöhe und von gegenseitigem respekt
getragene dafür bedanke ich mich dass
die fpö das innen ressort führt war für
alle diese erfolge die unabdingbare
voraussetzung
genau diesen verlust des
innenministeriums haben aber dem
bundeskanzler viele in seinen eigenen
reihen nicht verziehen denn dieses
ministerium war über viele man sollte
sagen viel zu viele jahre hindurch der
dreh und angelpunkt der motor einer
knallharten evb machtpolitik in dieser
republik
es musste also zurück unter die
kontrolle der evb koste es was es wolle
offenbar war es die annahme von
bundeskanzler kurz und seinen berater
stäben dass sich die fpö in der
regierungsarbeit schritt für schritt
entzaubern würde dass ich dieses problem
dass man hier durch die abgabe eines
vermeintlich schwarzen schlüsselressorts
produziert hätte sich von selbst
erledigen würde
gekommen ist es freilich ganz anders
denn die freiheitlichen minister unter
führung von vize kanzler strache haben
in ihren ressorts in wahrheit die
knochenarbeit dieses regierungsprojekt
es geleistet sie haben damit den kurs
diese regierung geprägt und sie haben
das inhaltliche bild diese regierung
geprägt vom kopftuchverbot
das zur erhöhung der mindestpensionen
von der reform der mindestsicherung über
die zusammenlegung der
sozialversicherungsträger bis hin zu
echten trendwende in der asyl- und in
der migrationspolitik um nur ein paar
ganz anschauliche beispiele zu nennen
überall waren es freiheitliche minister
die den takt und den kurs vorgegeben
haben
gerade in der zuwanderungs und
asylpolitik und das ist aus meiner sicht
einer der großen schicksalsfragen
österreichs und unseres kontinents gab
es auf diesen neuen weg sehr bald
widerstand und blockadeversuche durch
jene kräfte in der övp die mit linken
parteien koalieren aber dann auch durch
die parteispitze selbst eine ablehnung
des un migrations bugs käme nicht in
frage
die fpö hat sich durchgesetzt
lehrlinge mit einem negativ
rechtskräftigen asylbescheid dürfen
nicht abgeschoben werden
die fpö hat sich durchgesetzt die
einrichtung von aus reisezentren war für
die lvb unerwünscht die fpö ist
konsequent geblieben
und gerade zuletzt sollte die aus
freiheitlicher sicht mehr als gerechte
reduktion des anerkennungspreis für
asylwerber von 1 euro 50 die stunde
eingeführt werden
das ist hart mit der övp ausverhandelt
worden jetzt sollte es auf wunsch der
selben övp nicht mehr umgesetzt werden
die fpö war zu diesem schritt zurück
nicht bereit
genau diese klare und konsequente linie
des freiheitlichen innenministers kommt
bei weiten teilen der bevölkerung sehr
gut an
es ist die politik die sich die menschen
als reaktion auf die katastrophalen
fehlentwicklungen im jahr 2015
er war meine sehr geehrten damen und
herren
als vor wenigen tagen das inzwischen
allseits bekannte illegal aufgenommene
video material aus ibiza aus dem jahr
2017 aus dem ausland nach österreich
gespielt wurde da war für uns
freiheitliche und norbert hofer hat das
schon gesagt in der sekunde klar dass es
konsequenzen geben muss konsequenzen
personell sowie inhaltlich von einem
mangelndes problembewusstsein von
fehlenden verantwortungsbewusstsein im
umgang damit
oder von einer unterschätzung der
dimension der problematik kann nicht die
mindesten die rede sein
niemand von uns hat geglaubt dass man
angesichts der bilder und worte zur
tagesordnung übergehen kann
wir waren uns unserer verantwortung voll
und ganz bewusst
und genau deshalb haben wir mit dem
bundeskanzler auch einen gemeinsamen weg
gesucht was ist notwendig um das
vertrauen in der bevölkerung
wiederherzustellen und wie können wir
gleichzeitig im interesse der mehrheit
der österreichischen bevölkerung diese
so wichtige regierungsarbeit für das
land fortsetzen
gemeinsam mit kanzler kurz wurde am
freitagabend und am samstagvormittag die
notwendigen schritte definiert
der rückzug von hc strache und johann
gudenus aus allen politischen ämtern
die volle aufklärung aller im raum
stehenden vorwürfe rund um spenden und
vergaben die vorgangsweise den
bundespräsidenten norbert hofer für das
amt des vize kanzlers vorzuschlagen die
rasche erarbeitung auch eines pakets
wenn sie so wollen für einen moralischen
neustart mit einer neuen fpö
und für all diese maßnahmen wurde dann
auch ein gemeinsamer zeitliche fahrplan
für erklärungen am samstag erarbeitet
die fpö hat ihren teil der vereinbarung
gehalten
die övp hat im verlauf des
samstagnachmittags dann jedoch eine
völlig neue forderung erhoben
ich müsse das innenministerium verlassen
ich könnte ihnen ein anderes ressort
wechselt egal welches oder klubobmann
werden und es darf vor allem auch kein
anderer freiheitlicher mir im
innenministerium nachfolgen
dann können die regierung weitergehen
ich füge nur hinzu mir persönlich wurde
das nicht gesagt obwohl ich mehrmals die
gelegenheit geboten hätte in
entsprechenden gesprächen mit
bundeskanzler
kurz ich frage sie jetzt eines meine
sehr geehrten damen und herren wenn da
jetzt angegebene grund für ein
notwendiges ausscheiden aus dem
innenministerium
meine generalsekretärs funktion im jahr
2017 gewesen sein soll
warum kann dann nicht ein anderer
freiheitlicher der nie diese funktionen
inne hatte mir im innenministerium
nachfolgen und die konsequente
freiheitliche politik dort fortsetzen
ich erinnere sie auch wie norbert hofer
es getan hat noch einmal daran als es
wegen tatsächliche korruption zu
ermittlungen und prozessen gegen
hochrangige politiker wie zum beispiel
ernst strasser gekommen ist waren sowohl
das justiz als auch das innenministerium
fest in schwarzem hemd und ich wundere
mich manchmal dass der bundeskanzler
dieser republik oder seiner berater so
weit gehen einen tadellosen
beamtenapparat in die nähe des
amtsmissbrauchs zu bringen
das ist nämlich der vorwurf der bei all
diesen dingen im raum steht
und ich erinnere an noch etwas den
bundespräsidenten war es bei der bildung
dieser bundesregierung nicht
das im sinne sauberer
rechtsstaatlichkeit und klara
gewaltentrennung das justiz und das
innenministerium nicht in den händen der
selben partei sind für uns freiheitliche
war diese regelung eine
selbstverständlichkeit
obwohl in der vergangenheit unter sp
bundespräsidentin beide ressorts in
händen ein und derselben partei in
schwarzen nämlich gewesen sind für uns
freiheitliche ist diese vorgangsweise
der övp kein verantwortungsbewusster
oder kein staatstragender schritt es ist
nicht der versuch die regierung deren
arbeit von großen teilen der bevölkerung
in österreich geschätzt wird im
interesse der menschen vorzuführen
es ist der versuch uns allen einen und
es ist auch nicht der versuch uns allen
einen unnötigen und teuren wahlkampf zu
ersparen
und es ist auch nicht der versuch
verloren gegangenes vertrauen wieder
herzustellen
nein meine sehr geehrten damen und
herren es ist etwas ganz anderes
es ist der versuch die eigene macht
innerhalb der regierung auszubauen
es ist die absicht einen
regierungspartner zu knebeln
es ist die absicht eine spaltung in
seinen reihen herbeizuführen einen keil
hinein zu treiben wie wir das alles
schon einmal erleben müssen mussten
es ist ein rückfall wenn sie so wollen
in die untiefen der ovb machtpolitik die
dieses land so viele jahre gelähmt
gehalten hat und dazu können und wollen
wir freiheitliche keinen beitrag leisten
war es auf ibiza eine verantwortungslose
besoffenheit infolge von alkohol dann
ist das jetzige vorgehen der övp eine
kalte und nüchterne macht besoffenheit
meine sehr geehrten damen und herren
die eigenen interessen ohne rücksicht
auf verluste und ohne bedacht auf die
folgen für diese aktionen in kauf nimmt
die lvb wird sich fragen müssen was nach
den kommenden wahlen basiert sie wird
den österreichern erklären müssen dass
ein erfolgreiches projekt indem wir in
ganz wesentlichen und sensiblen
bereichen großartige erfolge vorzuweisen
haben mutwillig zerstört wird
was ich ganz besonders bedauere meine
sehr geehrten damen und herren ist dass
der bundespräsident die wahre absicht
hinter einem jungen und freundlichen
gesicht nicht durchschaut hat gerade das
zu tun wäre angesichts der situation für
ein staatsoberhaupt notwendig gewesen
ich erwarte mir jetzt eine solide
abwicklung der übergabe wir sind dazu
bereit
der normalzustand ist dass alle minister
so lange im amt sind bis neue minister
angelobt werden und das erfolgt im
normalfall nach einer neuwahl auf basis
einer demokratischen entscheidung
es besteht überhaupt kein grund dafür
einen alarmismus auszurufen oder eine
staatskrise herbeizureden wo man sich
dann als vermeintlicher retter
aufplustert es gibt keine staatskrise
was es vielleicht gibt ist eine
praktische krise der evb aber meine sehr
geehrten damen und herren ich habe ja
heute im verlauf des nachmittags noch
einen gesprächstermin mit bundeskanzler
kurz ich werde ihm dort noch einmal
erklären mir geht es um das wohl
österreichs mir geht es um das wohl
unserer bevölkerung hier geht es nicht
um meine eigene position
vielen dank
[Musik]
die pressekonferenz der fpl aus wien das
war die erklärung der beiden herren
norbert hofer bisher verkehrsminister in
der regierung und